vous n'aviez aucun pouvoir de décision
aucun pourquoi mexico
que faisiez-vous là bas
j'avais grandement besoin de vacances
alors james qu'est-ce qui se passe on
dit que vous êtes fini aujourd'hui de
quoi vous attendiez vous n'en est qu'à
vos débuts et magnifique normes
elle monte à 100 en 3 secondes 2 et elle
a plus d'un tour dans son sac
dernière chose à vous demander lavez vos
derrière la tête vous pouvez me faire
disparaître
dites moi où il est il est partout à la
fois
si vous allez là-bas vous passerez dans
ce monde qui ne connaît pas l'appétit
nous protéger quelqu'un laissez moi
émouvant
pourquoi je ferais confiance parce
qu'avec moi au moins vous avez des
chances de rester en vie
cette organisation vous connaissez son
nom elle s'appelle spectre savez-vous
qui fait le lien entre tous ces gens moi
bienvenue james
mille fois vous avez croisé mon chemin
mais sans jamais me voir vous en avez
mis du temps
c'est vraiment ça vous voulez vivre dans
l'ombre
traqué traquant les autres est toujours
seul
c'est pas ça qui m'encombre l'esprit
c'était moi tiennent ce
l'auteur de tous vos malheurs